Jack and the beant
stalk a version of the tale by the Fable
cottage.com
once there was a young man named Jack he
lived with his mother on a small farm at
the foot of the foggy
mountains Jack and his mother were very
poor their only way of making money was
selling the milk from their cow Bess
one morning Jack's mother woke him up
early it was still dark outside she was
crying Jack wake up go to the market
today and sell our cow
this but why asked Jack
yawning we need money to fix our house
there are holes in the roof the windows
are broken For Heaven's Sake with no
front
door Winter's coming soon if we don't
fix the house the cold will kill
us Jack packed his bag and fetched Bess
from the
barn as he was walking out the gate he
heard his mother shout she's worth at
least five gold
coins don't sell her for Less
when Jack was halfway to the market he
met an old
man good morning my boy said the old man
where are you going
today good morning sir replied Jack I'm
going to the market to sell my cow her
name is
Bess she is a beautiful cow said the man
I will buy Bess and I will give you a
very good
deal how much will you pay for her I
won't take less than five gold coins
said
Jack I don't have five gold coins
whispered the man but I have these five
black
beans these beans are magic beans they
are worth more than
gold if you take these beans you will be
richer than the richest man in the
[Music]
world Jack thought about his mother he
thought about how happy she would be if
they were Rich they could fix the roof
the windows and the front door maybe
they could buy a new
cow okay said Jack you've got a deal
give me the
beans Jack was very
excited he ran home and showed WR his
mother the beans but instead of being
happy she was
Furious you Foolish Boy you traded our
only care for a handful of
beans she took the beans and threw them
out the
window then she sat down beside the fire
and
cried Jack was
devastated he shut himself in his
bedroom room he felt so
stupid they no longer had a cow and now
they were poorer than
before what a
disaster and it was all his
fault the next morning when Jack opened
the curtains he saw something very
strange in the same place where his
mother had thrown the beans there was a
giant green beant
stalk it stretched from the ground up up
up all the way to the
clouds the Beans really are magic
whispered Jack the old man was telling
the
truth Jack's mother was still asleep so
Jack decided to climb the beant stalk to
look for the the riches the old man had
described just five gold coins thought
Jack that's all I need to make my mother
happy jack climbed up up up higher and
higher into the
clouds when he reached the top he was
very hungry he saw a castle in the
distance maybe I can find something to
eat in that castle he
thought Jack walked up to the door of
the castle and knocked twice knock
knock a giantess opened the door she was
as big as a house but she had a warm
smile and gentle
eyes excuse me Mrs giant said Jack could
you please give me something to eat I am
so
hungry oh you poor boy said the giantest
she could see that Jack was very thin of
course come in come in the kind giantes
gave Jack some vegetable
stew he was enjoying it so much that he
didn't notice when the kitchen table
started to
shake stomp stomp stomp loud footsteps
echoed down the hallway oh dear
whispered the giantess that is my
husband he's home from work he doesn't
like humans quick
he jack hid in the
pantry the giant stomped into the
kitchen and sniffed the
air Fe fire for
th hello my beautiful
wife wait do I smell a human man Y where
is he good evening my darling husband
replied the giantess there is nobody
here you smell the vegetable stew
nothing
more good grunted the giant I hate
humans he sat down at the table in the
kitchen the giant took a small sack of
gold coins out of his pocket and counted
them
1 2 3 4 five gold
coins Jack watched from inside the
pantry five gold coins thought Jack if I
had that money I could fix our
house when the two giants left the room
Jack stole the five gold coins and
slipped them into his
bag this is all I need thought Jack
but then Jack remembered that his family
no longer had a
cow without a cow they would surely
starve he decided to stay and look for
other
Treasures he followed the giant into the
living room and hid under the couch the
giant went to the cupboard and pulled
out a golden
hen hello my beautiful hen lay please
said the Giant and the hen laid a golden
egg Jack watched from under the
couch a hen that lays golden eggs
whispered Jack if I had that hen I could
buy 50
cows when the giant left the room Jack
crawled out from under the couch he went
to the cupboard took the hen and put it
in his
bag this is all I need need thought
Jack but then Jack thought about what
the old man had promised Jack imagined
being richer than the richest man in the
world he decided to see what other
Treasures he could
find he followed the giant into the
bedroom and hid under the
bed there was a Golden Harp standing in
a corner of the
room hello my be beautiful harp play
please said the giant the harp began
playing music with no one touching the
strings wow a magic har whispered Jack
that harp would make me Rich and
Famous when the giant fell asleep Jack
crawled out from under the bed he took
the magicarp and put it in his bag but
this time Jack was less
lucky the magic Harp
screamed help me master a human is
stealing me the giant woke up and saw
Jack with the magic harp the golden hen
and his gold
coins stop
thief the giant chased Jack out of the
bedroom down the hallway through the
kitchen and out the front door but Jack
was smaller and faster than the giant
Jack reached the bean stalk first and
slid
down he arrived at the ground with all
his
treasures the giant reached the top of
the beant stalk and looked down he was
afraid of
heights he slowly climbed
down be careful my husband shouted the
giantess from the castle humans can be
dangerous Jack saw the giant coming down
the beant stalk so he ran into his house
and grabbed an axe he chopped the bean
stalk whack whack
whack suddenly the bean stalk
snapped the giant came tumbling down
from the
sky he fell down down down down and
landed far away on the other side of the
foggy
mountains
thud for a moment everything was
silent then Jack heard a strange sound
from far
away
no it was the
giant the bean stalk had fallen and now
he had no way to get back up to his
castle in the
clouds the giant yelled so loudly that
the clouds Shook and turned
gray then somewhere up in the sky jack
heard Mrs giant start to
cry her tears fell through the clouds in
tiny drops and soaked the
Earth after that Jack and his mother
lived a very conf aable life the golden
hen made Jack a
millionaire the magic Harp made him
famous Jack married a rich and famous
woman and together they had 10
children but Jack was never truly
happy every time the wind blew Jack
heard the giant calling for his
wife and every time it rained he felt
the giant wife's tears falling on him
Jack felt sad and
guilty one day when Jack was very old he
decided that he didn't want to be sad
anymore he opened a box on his
mantelpiece and pulled out one last
shriveled magic
bean if he could find the giant he could
grow another Bean
stalk then the giant could climb back up
to his castle in the
clouds if he could find the giant he
could also apologize for being so
greedy Jack packed his bag and walked
into the foggy
mountains did Jack find the
giant did he grow a new Bean stalk with
the last magic
bean nobody
knows but people say if you listen
closely during a thunderstorm you can
hear the rumbling sound of two giants
dancing together in the clouds
[Music]